foreign
for CBS deals and this morning some of the most
popular items we've showcased from items for the
home cook to those on the Go and all at exclusive
low prices to start shopping now scan the QR
code on your screen or simply visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Ashley Bellman joins us with more
good morning good morning okay this is exciting
everything here is going to give you a little
bit more power power keywords starting with jump
smart this is the only device that I will ever
use to jump start my car because it is foolproof
it is also a 10 in one device you could use it
as a flashlight as a charger as a thermometer a
compass you name it it has it jump start your car
your truck your boat your lawnmower when you say
foolproof you mean it won't shock you exactly any
trouble so for 119.99 25 off today you can have
the power to restart your car all you do is Hook
the red to the red black to the black and if it
doesn't if for somehow you don't do that correctly
it just beeps it's not going to shock you so
you can do it okay for our home cook the power
to cook quickly and healthy okay this is called
the crisper lid you just put it on any 10 to 12
inch pan the deeper the better and then it turns
any pan into what like a convection oven or an air
fryer will do so it swirls the air around really
fast and it's going to give you crispy healthier
quicker cooked food it also comes with that nice
shelf to elevate the food make it happen a little
bit more quickly this is a no-brainer because
the air fryer takes up so much space it does in
the kitchen and this is only 32.99 45 off today a
secret I already got that for breakfast I'm just
gonna love it yes okay more power the power to
charge multiple devices at the same time so this
you put plug this into the wall it's charging
while it's plugged in you can plug in multiple
devices into this and it also is a device that you
can just put your phone on top and it will charge
and then there's a digital display on the top this
is only 49.99 today it is 38 off this is something
you will get so much use out of it's incredible
you said 49.99 yes 49.99 I have to say that these
usually are way higher exactly and super Sleek
come in multiple colors I feel like I want one of
these in every room in my house alrighty and then
it's a portable charger too now we don't see a lot
of these anymore so this is something that I just
for peace of mind the react seven in one this is
only 27.99 it's 44 off and this is just to have in
an emergency situation it has a seat belt cutter
it has a flashlight it has a window breaker that
will break the glass if heaven forbid you have
to use that there is an emergency alert SOS there
you go honestly it's small enough you could stick
this in your purse if you feel threatened set
that off you know flashlight charger everything
you could need and this is so small and Chic and
again 20 less than thirty dollars 27.99 power and
safe power safety a little bit of air fried food
everything we need how about that Ashley Bellman
thank you and of course we partner with all
of these companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today simply scan that QR code
on your screen or head on over to cbsdeals.com